remember that story we did about Donald
Trump potentially showing early signs of
dementia and/or Alzheimer's speculation
about Donald Trump from the mental
health community is actually surging
above and beyond that there are
psychiatrists at a conference at Yale
University
who said a few days ago that Donald
Trump has a quote dangerous mental
illness and is unfit to be President the
group of psychiatrists said that Trump
is quote paranoid and delusional and
that it's their duty to caution the
public that Trump's psychological
instability is likely a danger to the
country here's a quote from James
Gilligan a psychiatrist at NYU I've
worked with some of the most dangerous
people our society produces directing
mental health programs in prisons I've
worked with murderers and rapists I can
recognize danger from a mile away
you don't have to be an expert on danger
or spend 50 years studying it like I
have in order to know how dangerous this
man is another quote from dr. John
Gartner of Johns Hopkins University
Medical School he's an expert on
personality disorders he said quote we
have an ethical responsibility to warn
the public about Donald Trump's
dangerous mental illness going on to say
that Trump is displaying narcissism
delusion and grandiosity and started
displaying it even on his first day in
office remember when he asserted that he
had some kind of record largest
inauguration crowd in history an online
petition has been created by doctor
Gartner imploring that Donald Trump be
removed from office and it's not just a
big thing it says listen based on
article 4 of the 25th amendment to the
Constitution the president will be
replaced if they are quote unable to
discharge the powers and duties of the
office however you need Congress to
agree that that's the case and I don't
see that happening anytime soon Pat no
matter how wacky or erratic Donald
Trump's behavior is I think there could
be impeachment proceedings put forward
by Republicans on other issues but his
mental health is certainly not one of
them I and others have criticized mental
health professionals in the past
for publicly making assessments about
others mental health because protocol in
psychiatry is you don't diagnose
individuals that haven't been examined
in person by you doctor Gartner
responded to that criticism specifically
saying research actually shows that the
psychiatric interview is the least
statistical statistically reliable way
to make a diagnosis and the Yale Medical
School has said that these mental health
experts were discussing whether there
are other ethical rules that override
the traditions such as it's really a big
problem if the president is mentally
unstable anything normally you say that
about someone who you have very little
information about there's hours and
hours of Donald Trump speaking
off-the-cuff most of the time of course
sometimes he speaks with a veneer in
front of him but most of the time he's
just add living and speaking his mind
there's plenty of content that you can
sample from people wrote to me about
that people wrote to me and said listen
David it saying I should know my dad's a
psychiatrist a good psychiatrist should
be able to spot some of what we're
talking about through the TV screen
anyway since these are the types of
personality these are the types of
traits that are behavioral behavioral
and observe a bowl I guess the only
counter would be well everything you see
Trump do on TV is acting but I think we
have a hard time believing that that's
the case and I'm sure even though these
doctors disagree and think that maybe he
has a mental condition of some sort yeah
Harold Borstein takes the other opinion
and probably believes that Donald
Trump's mental health is the best out of
any president in history
I was thinking imagine if Trump
subjected himself to success psychiatric
evaluation and then that doctor puts
together a letter similar to the one
that we got from dr. Bornstein Trump has
absolutely the best memory he is the
most stable person emotionally that I've
ever interviewed of all presidents right
away I actually don't think it's a bad
idea though for presidential nominees to
undergo some kind of a publicly
disclosed psychiatric evaluation I mean
don't you think that that as well as
medical records and taxes should just be
the basic package so we can really
decide with all
the evidence whether someone is fit to
be President of the United States
perhaps I mean when it comes to tax
returns that's just always been a matter
of tradition we haven't had to urge
anyone to do it by law yeah we've always
had these three basic qualifications for
becoming president and to add a few more
I think that would be okay
I think we need to add a few and I know
that people will say well David it will
end up being applied in a discriminatory
way etc I don't know I mean when people
talk about requirements to be parents I
immediately have red flags go off where
I say there's there's that that is going
to be applied in an absolutely
discriminatory way if presidents just
have to undergo a psychiatric evaluation
I don't know that we're going to be
limiting the pool that drastically other
than most of the people who are
currently our elected officials will
still have many many people in this
country would be qualified to serve well
just like even to get your driver's
license there's things that you have to
go through tests and vision checks and
everything else yeah but to be the top
public servant in the country and the
most powerful person on the planet
indeed you don't need much doesn't make
sense to me
doesn't make sense to me I've discussed
this with us on our reddit discussion
forum david pakman.com slash our EDD IT